it's 1917 and here's Treasury engravers first
plate for war saving stamps as first of Liberty
loans gets underway on 31st of March President
Woodrow Wilson had risen from his bed gone to
the White House for Enda and himself typed
out the words he read to Congress April 2nd
said Wilson solemnly it is a fearful thing to
lead this great peaceful people into the most
terrible and disastrous of all wars but
the right is more precious than the peace
and on April 6 Congress votes a declaration
of war on Germany but war is a costly thing
and it's the people who pay the bill here
in Denver Colorado women on the homefront
do more than write letters to their men at war
even children and their mothers buy stamps for
every penny helps buy a victory and in front
of the US Treasury Building in Wall Street men
were used to big-money lead big drive for sale
of bonds here more dollars bought more bullets
and here in Forest Park st. Louis
300,000 people are gathered for
gigantic rally to boost sale of
stamps and barns in 5th big war
low men and machinery won the war but
dimes and dollars fought the battle too
Toledo was heavily behind the Liberty loan
and won a flag of Merit for aid that won a war